[Music]
[Applause]
tyw Hall of Famer won three Super Bowls
with the Patriots joining us here in
studio you can join him at mohagen Sun
the FanDuel sports book private
mezzanine for uh and a meet and greet
with the former Patriot Legend Hall of
Famer that'll be uh Sunday January 28th
how about that so you can watch the game
with Ty Law will you give honest
opinions during the game of guys that
you may like or not like I don't know
how to do anything else damn but give a
honest opinion so I'm going to come I'm
come straight from the hip like I always
do but uh it's going to be a good time
man man they're really supporting uh me
uh supporting my product and corvis
vodka man so we gonna have a damn good
time so tell everybody and whoever's
listening right now show up and show out
and let's watch the game have a good
time all right and by the way I didn't
know that the Hall of Fame has an
official drink yes I'm the official
vodka corvis vodka let me go ahead and
put it in the camera for y'all the
official vodka the Pro Football Hall of
Fame you know I had to get some of those
other guys out of there CU you know
everybody come in from a you need to get
a gold jacket around them oh no I got
them was being
made oh it'll be it'll be gold jackets
on these uh bottles in Canton but a
portion of every bottle goes back to the
players assistance fun the old school
guys that had to get jobs in the
offseason who wasn't as fortunate uh as
I am especially those guys uh the money
that they're making a day and you know I
and to be honest with you uh Dan I got
to pinch myself to say damn I'm in the
room with these guys I got a chance to
sit down and talk to the great uh Jim
Brown Franco Harrison to hear what they
had to go through so I felt that it was
my duty to you know be able to give back
in some capacity like that and you know
help them and if they're passed on we
help their widows as well well you are a
Hall of Famer and I'm uh Curious where
your Hall of Fame coach is going to end
up Bill bellich ah
a lot of people are saying I thought the
perfect fit would have been from a
Personnel standpoint would have been the
Cowboys but I see they're going to stay
with McCarthy all those things were
coming out uh I just didn't know if he
was going to be able to handle being
under Jerry you know the two alpha
personalities clashing bigger than life
personality which could you see him
retiring I can see that as well but um I
think he still wants to coach he has
something I don't know why and I'm going
to put it out there I don't know why the
hell Bill b will have anything to prove
or feel is that he has something well
there's Don Schuler's alltime record
that he needs 15 wins all right you
gonna get that faster going to
Dallas if you go Atlanta but at the same
time you know you know and I'm saying
it's all in fun it's a lot of good times
in Atlanta too maybe Bill might come out
the sh a little bit play a little golf
you know go to Magic City I don't know
did Bill ever have a good time with you
guys yes I mean he was always a a good
time like for for whatever reason when
it comes to the media he's but if you
catch him you know but party with you
guys no bill hell yeah he'll party with
you he he a drink with you especially
after you win the Super Bowl when he can
finally uh you know let his hair down a
little bit but every time after a Super
Bowl party bill is hanging drink and
having a good time hell go in his office
check the
refrigerator what you got in there huh
some beer okay some
corvis okay so you had to win a Super
Bowl for Bill to have a beer with you
you didn't have to but it has to be the
right setting but I'm telling you every
time we had the party and even when I
wasn't there the after party it's like a
like the monkey is just off his back he
finally won he can really enjoy himself
man he's really a cool guy the only time
Bill was really an ass was contract time
you know what I mean that's that's when
me and Bill didn't get along but other
than that man we the best of friends
okay what was that like when you're
trying to get a raise uh it's tough
because you know you got to go into it
every man is for himself he's working
you know for an or organization he's
trying to keep the cap down I understand
that at at that point in that moment in
time you know I'm basically an
independent contractor and saying hey
this is what my worth is so it's B like
a battle of wits but at the same time um
it's necess one of those necessary evils
when you come to our sport so your
fourth year you had what nine
interceptions yes you led the league yes
then you
renegotiate uh yes but I but I was
always played under um Pete Carroll's
contract I was never a bill bellich
uh contract guy is just when we had to
talk it was all about the renegotiation
why didn't Pete Carroll work in New
England I don't know Pete was awesome to
me you know I mean hell he made me the
highest paid corner in football so me
he's always going to have a special
place in my heart but I think I think
his personality didn't mix with uh the
New England culture for whatever reason
you know around there he was more you
know energetic more happy gol lucky
coming from a coach par sales to a p
Carroll it is a different personality
you know what I mean and I liked it a
lot of guys didn't I think I know Mr
craft and the GM at the time you know
Bobby Greer they were you know
interviewing basically on our opinion on
some players what do we think yeah I
gave him a a glowing recommendation of I
want to keep uh Pete Carol because I
didn't know who they were going to get
but then you know the whole circulation
about Coach bich coming that's when I
like okay I can work with that because
remember he was my DB coach in '96 when
we went to the Super Bowl so I had B
every day you know what I mean so it was
a different type of relationship so you
know I have a fondest for coach belich
and when he came the only thing I had to
get shocked about then is damn B got
brand new you who is this guy but but
understanding he has to he's the head
coach now he has to he's just not my
coach he's just not our coach he's
everyone's coach so that was a little
bit of adjustment period what was it
like when he would yell at Brady the
same as everybody else I mean he did not
hold back and you know if you talking
about low lights and it was it was one
of the highlights of the day for me of
the week as long as I wasn't on them
because you talking about hilarious you
know I mean it it was it was it was
comical because he would go on there and
just give you his on liners he didn't
care who it was like it's a roast it it
it is a roast you know what I mean and
Eye in the Sky don't lie so you always
want to go out there and put on a good
performance and bill bichi is going to
call you out and Tom Brady was
definitely not off
limits well that also sends a really
good message to the rest of the team
when Brady's not off limits that bill is
willing to criticize him way he would
criticize a rookie exactly and and and
that created you know that culture that
everyone was held accountable uh even
Tom Brady and I think Tom Brady wouldn't
want it any other way that's how we all
grew up that's how we all learn to be
Champions and and and protect one
another and we held each other
accountable as well because if you
didn't perform you didn't have to wait
for Coach bichette to come in we would
do it ourselves we Poli each other we're
talking to tyw the Hall of Famer won
three Super Bowls with the Patriots you
were at Michigan MH were you f freshman
when the Fab Five was there yes I was a
a freshman I was they was actually
sophomores so I came in the year after
those guys and uh you know good friends
of mine they they it was an incredible
atmosphere because everyone knows that
the University of Michigan is a football
driven type of school the Fab Five they
they changed that narrative you know
they were just as important if not more
important and uh the football at the
time of course not from a revenue
standpoint I mean it's like you got
100,000 people in there but it's just
known for that but they really changed
the culture when it comes to the
basketball at Michigan not that they
didn't have success before but it was
just like a phenomenon to have five
freshman come in and do what they did
and impact the school like they have you
know they had every everybody at the
games you know I mean we we went to
games but when the Fab Five oh we're
going to Games 55 lead we go every now
and
again Jim Harbaugh's future is it at
michig you may hope it's at Michigan but
but let's be honest of what do you think
Jim is going to do I think he's going to
take his time I would like to see him my
son goes to the University of Michigan
by the way and he's a sophomore there
and what he's done he can't go any
higher I would love him to come back and
do a Nick Sabin type of thing and keep
Michigan and continue to do so but with
the Nils and people basically got to
recruit and basically offer more money
damn damn near they getting in the pros
you know what I mean it's going to be
hard and I think talking to a lot of
coaches from college and the difference
between the pros is that you have it
offseason you don't have offseason so if
Jim can name his price and go where he
wants to go and he doesn't have to
recruit I think he's going to and just
just is my opinion I think he's going to
listen to it do I want him to leave
absolutely not because I mean he's done
something special but do you think he'll
leave if the right opportunity comes I
think he will you you know just because
of everything I just mentioned you have
taken the team to the National
Championship the first time ever in the
great tradition of Michigan football go
undefeated you can't go nowhere but down
yeah unless you do it again so I just
think you know the right situation he's
going he's probably going to take
advantage of that and not have to
recruit would you rather face Lamar
Jackson or Patrick
Mahomes you know what I oh that's a
right there because I would say Patrick
Mahomes I would probably rather face
Patrick Mahomes from a defensive back
standpoint because you know he's looking
to throw it first not that not that
Lamar doesn't but Lamar he can beat you
with them legs and I remember the first
time that we ever experienced something
like that playing against Michael Vic in
Atlanta and you can have your receiver
covered next thing you know this dark
comes out of nowhere and now you got to
go CH now you're chasing this receiver
now I got to go chase somebody as a
quarterback that that's just as fast or
not fast in a receiver I was never more
tired in the game in my life so I think
I'll take Patrick Mahomes and take my
chances of covering his receivers and
let him trying to stick the ball in in
and have to worry about covering and
looking back and seeing Lamar Jackson
running at me okay explain Michael Vic
to those who never got to see him play
Michael Vic was Lamar
Jackson Patrick Mahomes who else run
invol cam new Stevia all packaged in one
he was the first one that that can
really run and it was such a shock to
see he proba could have been he could
have been a tailback and he was fast he
was quick explosive so Michael Vic was a
one-of a kind man and like I said when
he came in and he he replaced Chandler
because I mean we were we were we were
kicking their ass right but when he came
in he almost brought him back and we
were tired like different level of
athleticism exactly right like they they
they they sat him down brought Mike in
we was like oh my God please we glad the
game is almost over because we don't
want to play this guy all
game uh you got a grudge against anybody
still after you you dislike somebody no
it's no wonder that I dislike because um
you know when we're out there playing
I'm not friends with nobody I'm not
trying to but like hin Ward if he no I
mean hin Ward I mean me and hind are
good you know what I mean but on the
field we were competitors you know what
I mean that's they got this one famous
shot that people love to show me where
hind War he got me up in you know face
mask and all that stuff but they don't
never show the end of the play so the
caption is is like he's giving me the
stuff but if you look at the end of the
play I damn they put him in the Gatorade
but but you don't you don't catch that
one but no he is a he's a he's a great
he's a friend a great competitor and I
hope to see him in the Hall of Fame day
should be ball of Fame how absolutely uh
what's the Tom Brady story you tell to
your your kids or your
grandkids well one of my favorite it's a
lot of stuff that I can't say cuz we on
a dam Patrick I don't want to get I
don't want I don't want to get you fined
I don't care I don't I can't get fined
okay but but I won't do that to you Dan
I mean something you got to keep is it
just the language yeah language and all
that good stuff I mean we we were young
we were winning but Tom Brady I will say
was Tom a Hall of Famer off the field
when he was
playing check his roster hell yeah he
was a Hall of
Famer everybody want to be tall of hey
both on and off the field Tom is a Hall
of Famer but I will say he was very
confident and I remember it was myself
Lor Malloy we having a we was coming we
was walking into uh the steakhouse we
have this big team dinner and Tom Brady
told me and lawyer said I ain't giving
this back that's exactly the words that
came out of his mouth so I hope you
don't get to find me because mine slip
every now and again I'm sorry guys it
slip every now and again so after Super
Bowl yeah so no that was going to the
Super Bowl he said I'm not giving it
back cuz that's when Drew got hurt oh so
that's how he felt he said I'm not
giving this back you know and he said it
with that and so you know I'm on it
that's the spirit you know you you
that's how you're supposed to think as a
young guy and lawyer was like we we we
like kind of laughing like well yeah but
how you got 100 you got a $100 million
man come when he come back oh that's his
job and that's just how it was back then
you didn't think you would lose your job
but confident were you of Brady I can't
say he he wasn't the Brady that he is
now and it wasn't the confidence in
Brady it was the confidence in our
defense so we didn't give a damn who was
out there quarterback whether it was
Drew or BR we were a defensive team at
the time and the strength you know was
that so we didn't know what to expect
from Tom so our whole thing was just
don't turn the ball over just control
the game don't turn it over we got this
and I mean we were one of like probably
number one defense at the time anyway so
I think you get it gets forgotten about
when you're talking about the whole
story but no one knew that Tom Brady
would be the greatest football player of
all time at that moment well I remember
late in the game and then John Madden
said you know you sort of let play for
overtime so he's doing the game and then
Brady decides or Bill decides they're
going to throw the ball downfield then
you put it in in uh you know field goal
range with vinary but at the time here's
the great John Madden saying you know
because Brady as your quarterback right
play for overtime take your chances no
that know that was the greatest show on
Turf and you talking about tired you
know we were tired defensively I mean
they had a lot of talent so you know you
play to go out there and win the game I
mean we knew we can play with him from
the first time we played with him but
man Tom he didn't shy back he didn't shy
he wasn't shy about the moment he was
out there ready to play but we wanted to
win so I don't think you want to take a
chance overtime with that great offense
they got five six Hall of Famers on
there and why did they use Marshall faul
as a decoy that that game no I don't
know if they used Marshal faul as a
decoy I'm going to tell you we had a
hell of a game plan with that so I
wouldn't say Marshal faul was a decoy we
were you made him a decoy damn right you
took him out of the game absolutely it
was somebody on martiall fa during the
during the whole week of practice and
anybody can that on that team can
contest and back me up that we had a
number 28 Jersey usually have the
quarterback jersey we had a number 28
Jersey somebody in red and we had the
practice squad guys rotating because
they were getting hit they were
basically the only ones that live you
know in practices so somebody hit
Marshal faul every single play that they
could no matter where he was at so we
basically had a spy on Marshall so
they had to they had to divert did the
Patriots spy on the Rams in their walkth
through at the Super Bowl I don't know
nothing about that so when I say spy and
they try to twist it I say it's like
spying on the quarterback we had a spy
on martial fa that means an individual
hit Marshall Faulk every time and he
comes in your area hit him if you look
at Willie mcginness one time you
remember when I think he got a flag for
it Marshall was just standing there go
knock the hell out of him you know what
I mean and that's what that's how much
respect that we had for him but at the
same time we wasn't going to let him
beat us and that's how coach bich did
the game plan uh he's Ty Law you can
visit with him coming up Sunday uh it'll
be the uh Sun Wine and Food Fest tickets
available for the first championship
game viewing party from 3 till 6 and the
second game that'll be 6:30 to 10 so
mohagen son FanDuel sports book and
you're able to say hello to tyw and have
some of his vodka yes coris vodka
everybody official vodka the Pro
Football Hall of Fame you leaving that
for me oh yes absolutely they're yours
yeah yep I'm sign one for them too you
so put it right here in the man cave
there no man cave it should be no man
cave in New England without corver box
did you ever have a sip of anything
before you played a game like or
halftime like whiskey or uh no we did it
in practice before you know Mike Vel
used to had a flask so we all go to vbl
and hit the flask and yeah some whiskey
or something but no I was a I was a
coffee guy you know what I mean that's
that's about it wait so vable has a
flask yes and then you go over and take
a little yeah then he had everybody else
getting a flask so so back then we used
to have to drive to practice too so
that's the one thing that uh you know
the old school before you see all the
beautiful uh Jette Stadium foxb now we
had to get in our car with our shoulder
pads on like we were little league and
we everybody driving over there with
helmets and shoulder pads on just being
silly and hell yeah we was taking drinks
in the car so coach parel's Pete yeah
when we were over at the other practice
facilities it was going down on that
little five minute
drive especially when it was cold
outside but never a game oh never a game
not not for me I I I've never uh uh
drank before a game I I I couldn't trust
I had to go out there and cover the fast
guys man you can't go out there covering
Marvin Harrison and Randy Moss to
alcohol in your system i' be on the
wrong end of the
highlights uh great to see you thank you
thanks for vodka and appreciate it man
congrats again on the Hall of Fame thank
he's Ty Law we'll take a break we're
back after this Dan Patrick Show